est ce que vous vous dites quoi dans ces
cas-là ce que je sais que vous êtes
comme une folle sur booba c'est que vous
voulez le pechoux à mort non mais moi ça
me fait rire aussi l'énigme et c'est
tout et hakam non mais oui on dénie en
ont d'ailleurs fait une soirée ensemble
c'est le way s'est jamais caché de jeu
qui fait aussi un ces voix là se pose la
question dont la plateforme est alors
oui alors donc pas aulas ouais oui oui
je la fais une soirée avec mais au delà
sage c'est quand même drôle et son badge
et qu'une bouteille de parfum de la
tapenade ou en parle pendant dix ans aux
states faire un père content is matt ça
finit souvent en sang et en améliorent
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'ils ont dit
boubacar sy ça ils ont dit qu'ils rôdent
rétif c'est un mauvais exemple sait
jamais au procès en tout cas ce qu'on va
retenir c'est la soirée de paula du pape
on a une petite photo je crois que ça va
surtout emmerder les autres rappeurs
parce que dans c'est quoi ce avant goût
de l'art on a quand même un non mais
attendez sans rigoler c'est quoi c'est
la de la capture d'écran qu'elle nous en
l envoyant peuvent à l'équipe
alors je lis que vous êtes disque à
l'honneur d'avoir passé la soirée assise
à côté du oui j'ai rêvé toute la nuit
que tu me la met à mal et merci
[Musique]
c'est pour dire à la lui avait très peu
de choses qui rime avec duke on comprend
le cas du magasin
c'est vrai voilà moi je prends et vous
êtes une artiste voix la voix ce que
j'ai aimé c'est la réponse de umag nu
mais ça mais il en tout cas le gars ce
n'est pas mal et médard kg remercie en
tout cas mr